vie de l'homme bonjour merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors
turquie la visite de sergueï lavrov à
chypre arrive dans un contexte de
tension assez vite on peut le dire que
date on en attendre qu'il appelle au
dialogue toutes les parties prenantes à
ce conflit
écoutez la situation est effectivement
extrêmement tendu du fait de la turquie
qui violent la zone économique exclusive
grecque et celle de chypre
les rapports sur les rapports entre la
russie et chypre sont étroits depuis des
années notamment économiquement avec
d'importants investissements russes dans
l'île de shikoku en tout cas dans la 2e
partie contrôlés par la république de
chypre puisque 40% près de 40% du
territoire sont occupés illégalement par
la turquie depuis et est colonisé depuis
donc on peut penser que cette que cette
visite vient pour parler avec les
responsables chypriotes de cette
situation de tension qu'entretient la
turquie et probablement pour leur
apporter une manière de soutien la
nouveauté dans la situation à chypre
c'est que la semaine dernière le
gouvernement américain a levé l'embargo
à destination de certaines armes non
létales et défensive à destination de la
république de chypre
donc on voit bien qu'il ya là un grand
jeu dans laquelle dans lequel il y à des
acteurs régionaux et puis les deux
grandes puissances que sont la russie et
les etats-unis qui garde sur cette île
qui est une espèce de porte-avions au
large du proche orient et au large de la
syrie dont vous venez de parler d'une
grande importance géostratégique alors
le dernier fait en date inséré cheptel
perdon qui a proféré de nous
elle menace contre les autorités
grecques à propos des ressources
gazières en méditerranée le problème on
a l'impression qu'il est bien loin
d'être finie ah oui oui le problème est
loin d'être finie si vous voulez il ya
des provocations turcs qui sont moi
j'habite si j'habite dans une île
grecque tout près de la couture que vous
voyez peut-être une coûte juste derrière
moi c'est la coupe de la turquie donc on
a on a des provocations qui sont
absolument quotidienne on a des
déclarations du président maire de gan
et de ses proches qui sont de plus en
plus incendiaire à l'égard d' à l'égard
de de la grèce à l'égard de chypre qu'il
menace de détruire à l'égard de la
france puisque la france a décidé de
soutenir le droit international et la
grèce dans cette et chypre dans cette
affaire en envoyant déjà plusieurs
rafales et en organisant des exercices
avec des bâtiments de la marine
française qui était dans les parages et
probablement bientôt en envoyant le
charles de gaulle puisque on va avoir
une réunion entre le premier ministre
grec et le président français en corse
jeudi prochain donc si vous voulez on
est dans une situation d'extrême tension
je dirais qu'il ya il ya une escalade
verbale depuis depuis dix jours mais que
en gros sur le plan des défaites la
turquie c'est un petit peu calmé
devant la fermeté grecque et devant
l'importance des soutiens qui a
recueilli la grèce puisque la grèce a
également le soutien des émirats arabes
unis de l'egypte hier il ya eu un sommet
au caire avec l'egypte l'irak et la
jordanie qui se sont mis d'accord pour
bloquer les initiatives impérialiste de
la turquie dans la région
et puis il ya également des revers en
libye
ou la russie comme en syrie se trouve
opposé à la turquie et où les plus pros
tueur que du gouvernement de tripoli ont
été limogé à la suite du de l'accord de
cessez-le-feu qui est intervenu il ya
une dizaine de jours donc si vous voulez
il ya un contexte régional qui est
extrêmement compliqué et dans lequel la
turquie aujourd'hui est très isolé alors
on va voir avec la visite de lavrov a de
monsieur lavrov à chypre si ces petits
allemands se confirme du côté russe mais
je doute que la russie étant et vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure elle elle est
attachée à l'intégrité territoriale de
la syrie
or qui menace l'intégrité territoriale
ou qui la met en cause c'est la turquie
puisque la turquie occupe une partie du
territoire syrien
donc donc si vous voulez il ya peu de
chances que monsieur lavrov viennent
pour donner un soutien quelconque à la
turquie voilà après la solution de cette
question et elle est inscrite dans le
droit international
et si la turquie accepté enfin
l'arbitrage de la cour internationale de
la haye sur sur les différends qui
l'opposent à la grèce
on aurait fait un grand pas il faudrait
que la communauté internationale exerce
là-dessus dépression et il serait bien
que l'allemagne
au lieu de soutenir en sous main la
turquie exerce une pression diplomatique
pour que la turquie acceptent cette
solution conforme au droit et à une
résolution du conseil de sécurité qui
remonte à 1975
olivier de leur merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
l'auteur de la grèce et les balkans
merci d'avoir été en direct avec nous